quien fuera jefe judicial de irán ahora
asume las riendas de la república
islámica
el clérigo ultraconservador ibrahim
rising perdió en 2017 contra el saliente
hassan rujan y considerado un moderado
en 2021 el consejo de guardianes impidió
que la gran mayoría de moderados
participaran en unos comicios marcados
además por una participación de apenas
el 48% raíz y cercano al ayatolá ali
jamenéi ganó con el 61% de los sufragios
estas elecciones son contrarias a
cualquier semblanza elecciones libres y
justas
es realmente esperar que salga raíz y
las urnas es una elección manufacturado
a la raíz y cuenta con un sombrío
registro cuando de derechos humanos se
trata eeuu los han solo en 2019 por su
supuesto rol como uno de los cuatro
jueces involucrados en ejecuciones
extrajudiciales de prisioneros políticos
en 1988 por las cuales organizaciones
como amnistía internacional han pedido
que sea investigado en una primera
muestra de lo que serán unas tensas
relaciones tras su elección israel lo
calificó como verdugo ibrahim rising
rechaza las acusaciones en su contra
pero uno de sus principales retos será
darle nueva vida a una economía golpeada
por las sanciones impuestas por estados
unidos ha demostrado apoyo a las
negociaciones indirectas entre teherán y
washington en viena para revivir el
acuerdo nuclear pero insiste en un
levantamiento total de los castigos
mi sugerencia de los eeuu es para que
cambien rápidamente sus acuerdos deben
levantar todas las sanciones y con eso
demostrar que son honestos
el kobe 19 ha cobrado más de 90 mil
vidas en irán y mantiene a la economía
frágil alto desempleo que supera el 10%
y una inflación que se mantendría según
analistas por encima del 40% al menos
hasta finales del año motivo por el cual
la lucha contra la corrupción es otra de
las banderas de racing